temmar en personne a volé le jeu des
buts et personnes que je m'arrête 1966
jacques brel est au sommet de sa gloire
il n'a que 37 ans et ça fait 15 ans
qu'ils donnent des concerts il est
habité par la scène et pourtant il
annonce que cette tournée sera la
dernière
fini les représentations les tournées
terminé les concerts impensable pour les
journalistes il ya quinze ans je me
prépare depuis que j'ai des vidéos pour
le sait en débutant que qu'on va
s'arrêter et puis j'ai un caractère tels
que je veux bien sûr j'avais de
regretter bien sûr mais ça n'a pas
d'importance si vous êtes sur un produit
en surnombre changer d'avis non il ne
changera pas d'avis et expliquent cette
envie d'ailleurs c'est pour aller voir
ce pour avoir le temps d'aimer justement
j'ai un rythme de vie où j'ai peut-être
plus très bien entendu mais j'ai envie
d'aller voir de sauvegarde et de l'ofppt
m'offrir le plan de moteurs fin janvier
ça
et
[Musique]
ça s'appelle la liberté la liberté et le
défi de se lancer dans d'autres
expériences artistiques
il faut vous faire des choses
dangereuses faut faire des choses qu'on
ne sait pas encore faire
il s'essaye à la comédie musicale au jeu
d'acteur et même de réalisateur sur le
tournage du film l'emmerdeur edouard
molinaro explique cette envie de remise
en question perpétuelle
c'est quelqu'un qui laisse les choses
derrière lui s'il puisqu'aucun qui
regarde qui regarde devant
il a abandonné le métier de chanteur
pour devenir comme comédien il a
abandonné où ils abandonnent le métier
de comédien pour devenir metteur en
scène il abandonnera le métier de
metteur en scène peut devenir pilote
qu'est-ce qui sera après avoir des
pilotes et navigateurs gens sérieux
exactement navigateur direction les îles
marquises là-bas jacques brel malades se
consacre à l'écriture d'un dernier album
à partir de demain
beaucoup d'entre vous poseront ce disque
sur leurs platines avec je crois une
certaine émotion
c'est le dernier brel un an plus tard
une embolie pulmonaire en porte
l'artiste aventuriers aura-t-il accéder
à son inaccessible étoile
[Musique]
danny mac
thomas les mcr
suivant des toits peu ma peau de mes
chansons comme importe le temps
[Musique]